>>> THE INDIANA DOCTOR WHO
HELPED A 10-YEAR-OLD ALLEGED
RAPE VICTIM FROM OHIO GET AN
ABORTION IS NOW TAKING THE FIRST
LEGAL STEP TOWARD A POSSIBLE
DEFAMATION LAWSUIT AGAINST AN
INDIANA ATTORNEY GENERAL TODD
ROKITA.
ROKITA SAID BERNARD WAS AN
ABORTION ACTIVIST ACTING AS A
DOCTOR WITH A HISTORY OF FAILING
TO REPORT AND SUGGESTING SHE MAY
HAVE COMMITTED A CRIME IN
FAILING TO REPORT THE ABORTION
IN INDIANA.
ATTORNEYS REPRESENTING DR.
BERNARD FILED A COURT CLAIM
NOTICE FOR MAKING FALSE AND
MISLEADING STATEMENTS ABOUT
ALLEGED MISCONDUCT ABOUT THE
DOCTOR.
JOINING ME NOW IS THE ATTORNEY
FOR DR. BERNARD, KATHLEEN
DELANEY.
THANK YOU FOR BEING WITH US.
THIS IS A NECESSARY STEP YOU
HAVE TO TAKE TOWARD A DEFAMATION
LAWSUIT.
WHAT ARE YOU ALLEGING?
>> WE'RE ALLEGING THAT MR.
ROKITA MADE FALSE AND MISLEADING
STATEMENTS ABOUT OUR CLIENT AND
ACCUSED HER WRONGLY OF
MISCONDUCT IN HER PROFESSION,
WHICH CONSTITUTES DEFAMATION,
PER SE.
>> WHAT DO YOU ALLEGE THE
CONSEQUENCES OF THIS HAVE BEEN?
>> THE CONSEQUENCES HAVE BEEN
UNBELIEVABLE.
THERE'S BEEN THIS INCREDIBLE
FIRESTORM KICKED UP, MR.
ROKITA'S COMMENTS INCITED PEOPLE
TO MAKE HATEFUL PHONE CALLS AND
LEAVE HATEFUL MESSAGES.
THERE HAVE -- SO IT'S BEEN KIND
OF A WHIRLWIND FOR DR. BERNARD
OVER THE LAST FEW WEEKS, BUT
SHE'S BEEN VERY EMBOLDENED AND
APPRECIATIVE OF ALSO AN
OUTPOURING OF SUPPORT THAT WE'VE
RECEIVED FROM AROUND THE COUNTRY
FROM OB/GYN DOCTORS AND FROM
LAWYERS AND LEGAL PROFESSIONALS,
ALL OF WHOM ARE HORRIFIED BY MR.
ROKITA'S CONDUCT.
>> WHAT SPECIFICALLY DO YOU SAY
WAS DEFAMATORY?
>> WELL, IT'S ALL SPELLED OUT IN
THE LETTER WHICH I HOPE YOU HAVE
A COPY OF, BUT IT'S BASICALLY
THAT HE ACCUSED HER OF FAILING
TO REPORT CHILD ABUSE, WHICH IS
FALSE, SHE ABSOLUTELY DID THAT
AND COMPLIED WITH THE LAW.
HE ACCUSED HER OF BEING AN
ACTIVIST ACTING AS A DOCTOR,
WHICH SUGGESTS THAT SHE WAS
PRETENDING TO BE A DOCTOR
WITHOUT A LICENSE, WHICH IS A
CRIME, WHEN IT'S OBVIOUSLY
READILY AVAILABLE TO HER LOOKING
UP HER LICENSE THAT SHE'S
ACTUALLY A DOCTOR IN GOOD
STANDING.
SO THOSE ARE TWO EXAMPLES.
AND THEN THESE RECENT STATEMENTS
FROM HIM THAT HE'S DOING AN
INVESTIGATION ARE ALSO
UNSUBSTANTIATED.
I HAVE WRITTEN TO MR. ROKITA
TWICE, HE KNOWS THAT I REPRESENT
DR. BERNARD, HE HAS NOT
CONTACTED ME ABOUT ANY
INVESTIGATION AND HAS NOT
REQUESTED ANY INFORMATION AS
PART OF ANY INVESTIGATION.
SO AS EACH OF HIS
UNSUBSTANTIATED CLAIMS AGAINST
DEBUNKED IN THE NEWS MEDIA HE
SEEMINGLY IS MAKING UP A NEW
ONE.
>> THIS IS A STATEMENT FROM THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE, IT
SAYS, QUOTE, THIS IS PART OF A
DIVISIVE NARRATIVE AND AN
ATTEMPT TO DISTRACT FROM THE
IMPORTANT WORK OF THE OFFICE,
INCLUDING THE DUTY TO DETERMINE
WHETHER PRACTITIONERS HAVE
VIOLATED THE STANDARDS OF
PRACTICE IN HIS OR HER
PROFESSION, AS WELL AS FEDERAL
AND STATE LAWS.
WE WILL DEFEND AGAINST BASELESS
CLAIMS.
WHAT DO YOU SAY TO THAT
STATEMENT?
>> WELL, THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
PROBLEMS WITH THAT STATEMENT.
FIRST OF ALL, INDIANA'S ATTORNEY
GENERAL HAS NO POWER OR
AUTHORITY TO INVESTIGATE FEDERAL
LAW, PERIOD.
SO HIS ALLEGATIONS OF HIPAA
VIOLATIONS ARE COMPLETELY BEYOND
HIS PURVIEW AND HE SHOULDN'T BE
TALKING ABOUT THAT AT ALL.
SECOND OF ALL, HE'S ACCUSING --
MAKING ACCUSATIONS OF SO-CALLED
CRIMINAL WRONGDOING AND THE
MARION COUNTY PROSECUTOR, OUR
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT, HAS
ALREADY CONFIRMED THAT THEY ARE
THE AGENCY THAT WOULD HAVE ANY
ABILITY TO CONSIDER ANY CRIMINAL
CHARGES, NOT MR. ROKITA, WHO HAS
NO CRIMINAL PROSECUTORIAL
AUTHORITY.
SO THAT'S A SECOND BIG PROBLEM.
BUT MAYBE EVEN MORE
FUNDAMENTALLY THE LICENSING
STATUTE THAT THEY ARE REFERRING
TO WHERE THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
ACTUALLY DOES HAVE SOME
AUTHORITY SPELLS OUT THAT THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL IS TO KEEP ANY
INVESTIGATIONS CONFIDENTIAL
UNLESS AND UNTIL A DECISION IS
MADE TO ACTUALLY FILE FORMAL
CHARGES.
SO HE'S LITERALLY VIOLATING THE
STATUTE THAT HE IS SUPPOSED TO
BE ENFORCING BY TALKING ABOUT AN
ALLEGED INVESTIGATION.
>> WHAT DO YOU WANT THE
CONSEQUENCE OR WHAT DO YOU THINK
THE CONSEQUENCE SHOULD BE FOR
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL?
>> WELL, THERE HAS BEEN A
DISCIPLINARY COMPLAINT AT LEAST
ONE DISCIPLINARY COMPLAINT FILED
AGAINST HIM BY THE FORMER DEAN
OF THE INDIANA UNIVERSITY MAUER
SCHOOL OF LAW AND THAT SHOULD
TRIGGER AN INVESTIGATION BY THE
INDIANA DISCIPLINARY COMMISSION.
SO MR. ROKITA'S LICENSE COULD BE
IN PLAY HERE.
HIS LICENSE TO PRACTICE LAW,
WHICH IS A NECESSARY REQUIREMENT
FOR HIS ROLE AS THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL.
SO THAT PROCESS IS UNDER WAY.
AND THEN WITH OUR TORT CLAIMS
NOTICE WE'VE PUT HIM ON NOTICE
THAT WE ARE CONSIDERING FILING A
FORMAL LAWSUIT AGAINST HIM 90
DAYS FROM NOW.
HE'S REQUIRED TO INVESTIGATE THE
ALLEGATIONS IN OUR TORT CLAIM
NOTICE AND IT'S AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR HIM TO TRY TO RESOLVE THIS
DISPUTE OR TO INVESTIGATE IT OR
TO IGNORE IT, THOSE ARE HIS
THREE OPTIONS.
BUT WE CERTAINLY HOPE THAT HE
WILL GET SOME GOOD LEGAL ADVICE
BECAUSE HE SHOULD NOT CONTINUE
TO DEFAME MY CLIENT, BUT HE
STILL HAS DEFAMATORY STATEMENTS
UP ON HIS WEBSITE, HE STILL HAS
NOT TAKEN DOWN TWITTER AS OF THE
LAST TIME WE CHECKED THAT WE
THINK CONTAIN DEFAMATORY
STATEMENTS.
FIRST AND FOREMOST, WE WANT HIM
TO STOP SMEARING DR. BERNARD.
>> KATHLEEN DEE LANNY, THANK YOU
FOR JOINING US AND EXPLAINING
THE PROCESS YOU ARE GOING
THROUGH RIGHT NOW.
APPRECIATE IT.